health care leaders in Jamie Cross's
hometown are ready to do whatever is
necessary help this young girl adjust to
her new life the 13 year old teenager is
trying to deal with the trauma for
abduction and her parents murder DeMarco
Morgan shows us what experts say should
be done to help her recover he's at
Riverview middle school that's in Barron
Wisconsin where Jamie Claus was in the
eighth grade
DeMarco good morning good morning to you
you were out here for quite some time so
you understand why trauma expert n
survivors are saying what Jamie needs
most is time she needs to be able to
move at her own pace and at her own
terms and while she has yet to return to
school school officials say they will be
ready to greet her with open arms when
she does we still don't know exactly
what horrors Jamie cloths may have
endured while imprisoned in this
dilapidated cabin for 88 days and
witnessing her parents murdered now that
she is safely back with their loved ones
this community is coming together to
help her heal I don't think any of us
who have never been through it can even
try to put ourselves in those shoes
Stacy frolicked the Barron County Health
and Human Services Director says costs
and her family will get whatever
assistance they need from her agency
therapy access referrals resources
potentially for some financial
assistance if needed to the family three
of Clauses relatives told Gayle King
they are not probing her with questions
that might be traumatize her or pushing
her to tell her story before she's ready
we have a lot of steps ahead you know
baby steps a lot of different emotions
are gonna come out all stick together
she's shy she always has been but she's
she's getting there
the rare and unusual circumstances of
clauses are deal made complicated
recoveries as Robert Lowry jr. of the
National Center for Missing and
Exploited Children her life has been
completely shattered by this individual
who also held her in captivity in
overdose three months that probably
unspeakable things that involve this
child
Rowlett says counselors have also been
sent to help Clauses classmates since
her return the children are responding
in different ways fear joy sadness
and so there are supports that are
established and will continue until
they're no longer needed and she says it
may take time for clothes to return to a
level of normalcy after her abduction
it'll be a new normal but will she get
there I think she will get there now
frolic also points out that this is not
just one person or one families struggle
it's a struggle for this entire
community and she's asking anyone out
there that needs a mental or emotional
support to contact her Department
immediately Liana such good feedback and
DeMarco mentioned you know this is a
community struggle right now it's not
just about her it's about the family in
the community really yeah the family
told me the other day that she has
expressed an interest in going back to
school nobody and they took that as a
very good sign and the fact that she's
talking and laughing is really
remarkable when you hear what we heard
that's in that report but they also said
they are working on Jamie time I like
how they call it that they're working on
Jamie time everybody will work according
to her schedule and her desires and her
wishes Elizabeth Smart was saying
yesterday there are seasons to these
kinds of recoveries and she has to set
the pace and Elizabeth also said you'll
never be the same you'll never be the
same but you will get through it and it
doesn't have to define her exactly right